a moria y yo
cuatro años han pasado desde que jean
carlos y su familia llegaron a colombia
desde venezuela pero ese tiempo no acabó
con la discriminación que los rodea
especialmente a sus hijos en el primer
grado que estuve estudiando unos niños
le clavaron una punta de la piel en la
pierna verdad y entonces
cuando fuimos a reclamar la profesora
dice que nosotros no tenemos derecho a
reclamar porque porque somo venezolana
cruzaron una extensa frontera para
toparse con otro tipo de barreras unas
que se dirigen sobre la xenofobia y que
crecen ante las elecciones
presidenciales todas votaciones en
cualquier país afecta directamente a
toda la población que esté y sobre todo
más a la población migrante nosotros
ahorita estamos en una zozobra porque no
sabemos qué es lo que va a ocurrir con
nosotros
son estos momentos de tensión política
que le dan sentido al barómetro de
xenofobia alejandro un joven venezolano
es codirector de la plataforma que
monitorea los discursos alrededor de la
población migrante los comicios
presidenciales encienden sus alarmas
analizamos también todas las
declaraciones que han dado los distintos
candidatos a la presidencia y candidatas
la mayoría ha sido una gran ausente esto
es preocupante porque finalmente unas
políticas más importantes que estuvo el
gobierno de eeuu que una de las pocas
que se felicitó a nivel nacional
internacional ha sido la integración de
las personas migrantes venezolanas con
política migratoria primera que no hace
eco en la sociedad colombiana una
encuesta de invamer muestra que 60% de
la población no está de acuerdo con que
el gobierno acoja a los migrantes
venezolanos lo que hemos visto es que
cuando se incrementan los niveles de
xenofobia hay mayor posibilidad de
vulneración a los derechos de las
personas migrantes
en medio del panorama gris sobresalen
algunos destellos
como los platos de comida que entrega my
ir a una voluntaria venezolana en este
comedor comunitario a través de este
programa hemos logrado
bajar la discriminación e incluso
tenemos un comedor que es
mayor parte para migrantes venezolanos
entonces ha sido una manera también de
integrarlos a la comunidad a la sociedad
donde en este momento están haciendo
vida pero estas iniciativas no son
suficientes en 2021 más de 60.000
hogares migrantes no tenían acceso a la
salud y más de 200.000 vivían en
hacinamiento crítico unos pendientes a
los que se enfrentará quien llegue al
palacio de nariño